Hey youtubers surprise, suprise special
gameofthrones video today just because
they announce details
for the behind-the-scenes special they're
going to be airing. Just like last year's
the for shadowing special last year
It will be a full half-hour and visit all the filming locations. They have three big locations
Belfast Northern Ireland, Dubrovnik and
Split
in Croatia, Sevilla and Osuna and Spain.
The for specific scenes they will go to
the smaller places like Kastel
since this is a special that they'll be
airing on HBO before the season
I don't expect them to go to Super
Spoiler-y places.
This means that what they probably end up showing will be fairly general.
I will do a full breakdown once the
special airs so we can talk about the
scenes that we think they filmed.
There's always like a fine line I try to
walk when talking about behind the
scenes stuff.
I can actually do videos like this
while they're filming, there are always
a lot of pictures from the set
The problem is half the
people don't want to talk about it and
half the people do, so I always try to walk the line.
The best thing you guys can do
when we do videos like this is just
tell me, what specifically do you
want to talk about the most.
Do you care about the scenes they might
be filming already?
Or do you want to talk about something completely different?
As much feedback as possible is always
appreciated, thank you very much!
Just to give you an idea for what the special is going to look like
Here's the special from last year again
It's gonna look a lot like this, it'll bounce back and
forth between interviews with the cast and crew and behind scenes stuff but they will be
talking to the crew a lot
just because to be talking about filming
the actual episodes
how the
see to sleep
walk the world there is
tremendous clamor for revenge especially
in the wake up the red wedding
captain stocks death rich
bottom and in a chaplain that moment
I knew it was coming a dick killing wit
me up inside
crimes shirt you are yeah showed it to
you
on from teens were extraordinary
three motions to do
it's sorta where do you go from there
cinema most shocking and mind-blowing
scenes are the entire series come
the end of this coming season bloody
confrontations
I know how important the Redwood
ministers so many fans at the show
in the books but we pick up pieces and
top
in many ways this is definitely the most
dangerous season pretty re it seems like
almost every episode is in
jeopardy killings had removed from the
shoulders Syrians there've been faced
with this much public humiliation
usually has an answer for life to myself
thousand homes PULTURE don't talk my way
out
this he's usually center stage usually
is
better at it than the people around him
this time around
means left as a an audience member
I'm killed be mutual there's no
boundary with her interior a inflicting
emotional damage
she's quite happy to do it chief SPT
good
trooper he'd kill us all if he could
Syrian Jamie definitely have a low that
Tyrion doesn't have with the other
members of his family
and help steer Ian great deal this is
your mass-produced car
a royal wedding its history time has
come
for us all to contemplate history
terms the challenge to the wedding it's
the entirety of its that good healthy
massive team which takes up about half
the episode it was like shooting a short
film itself
actually shocked by the she is
scale really never seen anything like
that
in game Thrones find it very hard
I would have a wedding ceremony
replicated
like that again like career his majestic
shimmering and just look pristine
into just like likes yes something
ostentatious and brand
gritty but the show is that like to put
your into atmospheres
and into environments that conjure up
certain feel inside a few when the plane
scenes out your imagination is kinda
field
still there my training is a many
tropical version
love a West us thing said is
unbelievable I walked in on the site
open mouths a good 10 minutes very
intimidating
media is love me from the hot buttons
comment free she exploring what kinda
leader
she could be how can I Seven Kingdoms
if I can't control a single city this
city's that danny has previously
liberated
are beginning to you revolts becas it's
all well and good going in and
cutting the Thai and seemingly breaking
people 3
if you don't leave them with any
structure for any kind
a commander he shares the same morals
& Views is the person who liberated them
then it's a free-for-all
they can live in my new world or they
can die
in their 0
when the dragons were first born they
were adorable
babies and and I completely devoted to
their mother in the community
matter the cheese in the Grail
teaches in a bit of a little bit more
dangerous other
point where not babies anymore they are
outs
growing the restrictions that she's
placing on them she's always
idiot I mean for goodness sake the
Dragons they've killed her
enemies was gonna stop killing his
dragons in
in a non dragging well the Dragons
college
they can never be tamed think it's kind
of a simple have had leasing Angela
myself
unease controllers what she's doing 1
the thing that I got most excised about
is
John is not the same from season to
season
miss too much that's happened to him too
much thats gone on and that he's had to
learn
from
we find in season 4 he's in a very bad
places for hours how he feels he treated
a group in his honor
because nobody breaking his fast much
work for breaking his fast
he's in a lose-lose position really but
he has to make good
he did nothing wrong complaint
is reunited sound which is a good thing
but their relationship changed some
Injuns relationship issue is a
is as even and
equal as it's ever been this from
confrontation between the season
know what linger she will love the red
my girl how much she was pushing it's a
very different relationship we find
themselves in
still a loving wants to carry more
nothing without sound John would crumble
own web today the worm involves
prosthetics well
them up I can find a client-side when
the most terrifying things around today
was the open show season 3 want to get
this feeling
have something being behind sounds and
an impulse use so they decided the only
way to achieve that
with Chase me on the quad bike through
the snow
and the other guy running alongside
sailor the reason I'm here
if you fall over I'll get the quad bike
to stop potentially want to know the
pain you
but is not enough sometimes creating CGI
rules is strange experience she big
green sausage dummy
shoved in your face and you have to
treat it as if it's you lifelong passion
love it
bit is very alt the most sweeping I've
had to do this
season is to bite of man's here
do you think I
for someone to the castle black said I
thought oh my god because
to the step into it physically when it
comes out your head and into the real
world
eat tens chills down the spine chirping
of
the on grey jerseys companion was
because Hinchey Lorenzo pop-up
Ridley every day on the show is an OMG
moment really because there's always
surprises and
you're always in a pretty cool location
grateful
of a day the Fed credible that thing is
amazing about
the places we shoes start expects turn
up
you like she's its much grander than
market expected
canoe ever imagine his gmail min is when
you think you nearly finished
you've got five hours to go me
well nikolai Anna arm tried to do a
dance number
walking down the steps court we thought
it was fun
and that the extras with a laugh again
dancing but to the crew was really tired
I don't think they responded and they
were just heard from the 80 like still
rolling
reset whenever maybe surrounds there's
usually a loss the papers
and Mike do not lock months on people's
detailed
you know you'd see Dame tu anari eg
playing
playing backgammon with Daniel Portman
Selena giving massages someone and
events just chatting and joking around
that's a really nice moment everyone
else gets that s quite
I think the best quotes bronze quotes
any line he has witty and intelligent
hilarious you didn't fight with on a
shows no he did hmm
okay with a thin where he said or long
Odom hodel that allows them the bottom
but I think you would be when I'm egrets
hedges on that book
strike our country twins come back and
haunt
another great I'm but there's one day
here when she's
talking about nothing maybe nothing
is worse than this nothing isn't
poll working nothingness
just napping
think that make you rethink about active
kinda puts things into
perspective I'll check Rs
decade
definitely I believe that's probably the
most badass quite
I think as in previous seasons there's a
building what makes the season different
is that things really get going
much more quickly its more thrilling
throughout
in season three laws
there's definitely objectively more
action there a lot of things on the
production front that we've never done
before
everyone's kinda now loading gonzo
narrows
shopping then
lives at least right it's not building
towards ones specific climactic
event there more climatic events
in season for than they have ever been
for every season up until now it's been
episode 9 has been the big games season
is chips very steady the stakes are
higher
throughout the season the happen before
this season
story just gets more
intense some greedy GC
meant storyline chief chill through it
fight buttons pressed them under it's
all readers
for me to the floor here and the love
action
the good guys coming back here and p
yet where make you hope people when they
come out of the season
mobile field that the impact the season
as a whole
would be greater than the impactor the
previous season
her so many quality shows on television
that I love and
and admire but I don't think there's
moment the scale
game terms size cast terms
number countries we shootin and Shh
Pena who else has dragons really
Just like I said yesterday in my Mance video,
my next bonus video is going to be a
character video, but then
they'll probably be posting the trailer after that.
So the video right after that will be the trailer.
be sure to subscribe to get everything!
If you have special requests for bonus videos
let me know!
and right now while you wait
you can click here if you haven't seen
There's the Mance video
and you can click here to learn all about
Qyburn. Thank you so much for watching
So let's all High Five and I'll see you guys tonight!